hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna
review the trailer today for Furious 7
it's the next installment of The Fast
and Furious franchise everyone is raving
about this Super Bowl TV spot so let's
uh let them to see you with all the hype
is about
looks like this one did all of us home
remember no one show this is a big bad
brother
this
whoa
yes
why e s is one thing I find a little
funny I don't know why but the whole
family theme like it's a [ __ ]
action-adventure film about [ __ ] cars
being awesome life athletes theme is
just this seems a little forced to me in
this franchise but it the corniness of
it I think adds to the franchise
actually the Dominic's house blew up I
didn't see that coming I was a little
bit surprised - that house has been
around for like four movies or something
so it is a good way to establish this
villain up front like they're putting
Jason Statham in this trailer they
really want audiences to know like hey
he's in this film I like how they're
really promoting a villain this time
around like people are gonna be going
for the action the cool car stuff the
fun and everything but there's gonna be
a bunch of people actually going now to
see Jason Statham in the Fast and
Furious franchise this might be the
first time that a lot more people are
gravitated to this film because they
actually want to see an actor in it I'm
not gonna lie whenever Jason Statham
fights in movies all the fight scenes
look the same as every other [ __ ]
Jason Statham movie and even in this I
was like yeah it looks like transporter
crank and every other thing he's done
but whatever and then diesel says one
last ride in this trailer I call
[ __ ] I call major [ __ ] matter of
fact I think I read some [ __ ] report
that said that they're gonna be doing
like an 8 and 9 no no this hold one last
ride thing not so long I just want to
point that out it's not making me want
to see the movie ting less I'm just not
sold on it the rock I think it's called
the Gatling gun the rock when he's using
the Gatling gun like we got a different
shot last time it was leavin closer and
clearer this time around I really loved
that shot that is just gonna be like the
coolest [ __ ] moment effort with his
outfit he does look exactly like he's
got a GI Joe retaliation in that moment
but I'm ok with that
I like a good catfight when two hot ass
[ __ ] are knocking each other up wait
I don't mean like that [ __ ] each
other up there literally fighting and
hitting each other in the face and I
think that is hot and cool like
nothing's hotter than a chick who can
fight part of my foreplay in life is we
put on Marshall
arts equipment and then we fight maybe
sexual activities of the norm might
presume but more than likely I just like
getting hit in the face by someone's
foot how can you not talk about that one
moment we're Jason Statham is firing the
gun at that red car not even gonna
attempt to guess what kind of vehicle it
is I'm gonna be upfront don't know [ __ ]
about cars really when it's flying
through the air and it could be to the
other building I love the way it was
captured because it kept cutting back
and forth and slow-motion you know it's
gonna get across with the weights done
looks really cool then they cut to the
people inside the building for a little
pit anyone loves a good moment when you
jump out of a car then you're hanging at
the edge like that looks cool but the
way it was captured I mean it still
looks a little CGI ish but for the most
part I thought it was [ __ ] sweet
anyway guys thanks a lot for informing
me and that trailer was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe be
the real rejects and as always well not
always every once in a while we do
shadows zach johnson he said hello my
name is Zach Johnson I'm from new
Preston Connecticut and I'm 20 years old
anyway you may better know me about my
youtube name wolf 1994 I do you know you
better by that name and I commented on
Avengers age of Ultron trailer number
two reaction in review and asked for a
shout-out Zach Johnson of course you can
have a shout out your from new preston
connecticut where all the hot spots are
where all the love goes down the drugs
the parties the alcohol and totally
kidding you're in one of the most boring
parts of the world how do you live with
yourself of course you're watching a
youtube show what the [ __ ] else is there
to do out there I'm kidding
I don't know anything about new Preston
Connecticut was a concen you sound like
a cool guy I'm proud of you and you
should continue to they say touching
yourself is good for you despite what
Catholic school will teach you it helps